[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app it's the
tick-tock King Chris D'Elia and it's
episode 129 and we love in it man let's
uh Detroit
you got bless Detroit man you guys first
show selling out already I think it
might be sold out at this point so the
destroy babies I don't know if has to do
with M&M or what dude but you guys
really came through really appreciate it
really preach you know and let's see
where I'm gonna be I'm gonna be in San
Jose and I'm gonna be in Las Vegas and
Santa Barbara Riverside San Diego
Foxwoods Bethlehem Rochester New York in
the Buffalo and then I'm shooting my
special after new Buffalo and I'm doing
it in Minneapolis Minnesota
so Tampa Florida as well another show
went on sale because the first one sold
out you guys are the best even though
some of you guys probably killed people
or something like that anyway it's it's
it's it it's Monday and I was in
Atlantic City I did some shows in
Atlantic City and I did some shows in
Tarrytown Tyre town is this place in New
York I would tell people in the city
they'd be like where you're performing I
said Tarrytown they said what's that
that's crazy to have a place that the
whole [ __ ] place doesn't know where
it is you know I'm talking about so you
know get on the level man New York
understand what Tarrytown is because
it's in your [ __ ] state so you know if
somebody says California and they're
like hey San Jose I know where
[ __ ] that is men although there probably
is our places but I even know where
reading is man in California could you
imagine how smart I am
I haven't know where reading is so go
uncured self
yeah dude who knows what this episode
will be called who knows what's going on
I keep I got this big news coming out
today and I keep waiting for it to come
out so I can announce on the pockets but
it's not out yet so I can't say it but I
promise some big news and they told me
that it was gonna be dropped they have
to drop it first as the thing that I
can't say but it's very cool and there's
also my brother started a podcast Matt
D'Elia so go check that out and it just
came out today and you know I was in
Atlantic City guy New Jersey I'm from
New Jersey and I love New Jersey and
it's so New Jersey dude through some
guys out in the crowd of course because
so New Jersey I had but yeah I've been
on this tik tok kick man dude tick tock
I keep talking about it
and it's a very cringe app and I
realized that I only do a apps like
social media apps like I realize cuz
like with like vine and like even even
Instagram its huger it was a little
different but like I'm always I always
feel like I'm doing an impression of
someone doing the actual [ __ ] on the app
like I'm never actually I never feel
like I'm actually doing it but I suppose
I am and you know it's like if you're
doing it ironically you're still kind of
doing it and that is kind of it's like
I'm in a way I'm kind of the hipster
that's got the [ __ ] ironic mustache
that curls up it's like you're still a
dick for having it even though it's a
joke you still look like that and I'm
angry for it are you wearing suspenders
ironically you still look like a [ __ ]
barber in the 1820s and I'm angry at it
you know so yeah you could wear
wire-rimmed glasses and too much gel and
have it curl over your [ __ ] forehead
you can do that in Williamsburg but I'm
still angry just as I would be if you
meant it anyway I was in yeah so but I
do it so I did a man and I did it man it
makes me laugh that tick-tocks make me
laugh dude I saw a guy doing a tech talk
the other day and there was a part where
it goes where the guy on the song goes
rah and the guy who goes like this
like [ __ ] trying to be sexy dude
anytime a guy tries to be sexy you're
not sexy you can't be sexy except by
mistake as a guy a girl can [ __ ] do
the thing where they they get out of a
pool and whip their hair around and they
know they're doing it because her tits
are all out and [ __ ] and guys are like
fur you can mean to be sexy as a girl
for a guy if you mean to be sexy you're
making [ __ ] dry it's all good
but [ __ ] turning to the Sarah Hera
dude if you're a [ __ ] dude and you're
thinking I'm goddamn sexy you making
[ __ ] dry so yeah it's not cool it's not
cool to be sexy as a dude it's just cool
to be a dude like put this is as sexy as
you can get as a do it and know it put
it on a leather jacket and being like
wow there's little jackets dope that's
as sexy as you can get it to do it if
you're like these dudes you know these
[ __ ] dudes are chicks bro if you're a
dude and you're trying to be sexy guess
what you got tits your check okay cool
moving on all good hey dude it's all
good the conversations over and it's
fine that your chick but your check and
I saw I was in a I stayed in New York
for a night or two I can't remember how
long who knows all the day's run
together everything's the same and it's
all good but um and I walked in a Nike
in Soho dude it's like hilarious how
much they just
jump on board with whoever the MVP is
it's that Greek dude what's his name the
lover that MVP was this year he's Greek
as [ __ ] and my and dude I walked into
the Soho night Nike and it was like
unbelievable dude they were serving
coffee and Greek cups everything was
blue and white
giannis well obviously go up so I can
read the name and take Hong Kong tocome
PO so that's all good so that's his last
name
Yannick Hong Kong Kong Kong Kong come on
PO so he was the thing and dude
everything was Greek everything was
[ __ ] Greek it was so crazy they gave
you falafel as you left is that even
Greek I don't know nope who cares it
doesn't matter
dub Matt I don't like falafel that's it
that's as far as that conversation goes
don't like falafel and I don't like you
know what I don't like heroes Hey
all that stuff belongs not in that thing
beef belongs on its own if you got like
a chunk of beef don't put it in a
sandwich we're trying to do stop up your
colon hey hey oh dude I would eat a hero
except I'm trying to [ __ ] sometimes I
feel like when you eat a hero you eat
the gyro and you break it up in your
mouth and you chew it and then it goes
down in your stomach and then in all
forms again it's like the [ __ ] t2t mm
or whatever it is that you could blast
it open but then when it melts and it
gets in your stomach basically that's
the thing and then it just congeals and
it becomes a hero again and then it
stops up your colon cool euros dude also
gyro my opener loves euros but he farts
on the ground so it's all good how
[ __ ] every time he sees euros i guy
could take hero dude he's such a CUDA
man you got you know a Philly
cheesesteak every time we go to
Philadelphia's like I gotta get the
Philly cheesesteak man it doesn't matter
where you got about a [ __ ] car wash
he's like I got Philly cheese cakes yeah
I'm gonna need one but euros meat or
sandwich wrap
it bursts had developed in Bursa this is
not a part of your back whatever dude it
doesn't you know along say yeah but Nike
was so Greek themed it was unbelievable
it was like they're just like oh we
[ __ ] love it we love we just jump
onto their heritage they're just like oh
we love it we love it we're Greek dude
did you know that we have Greek
employees that guy is we were talking
about who's like if that cuz he's like
610 and he's like really good and then
my buddy was like yeah he could be the
next like LeBron and I was like yeah but
LeBron is a superstar cuz LeBrons
handsome you know my buddy was like
LeBron is not handsome and I was like
he's not he was like I don't know I
can't tell how about guys who pretend
that they can't tell if other guys are
handsome or not because they think it's
I think it's gay and they're so so
homophobic it's not it's not a it's not
it's you're not you can tell if a guy's
handsome just because he doesn't you
know him to be gay you know
but the one thing I do want to talk
about actually did on the flight out to
I got so delayed but on the flight out
to where was I going
dude this is unbelievable just wait for
this I got to go to our text chain cuz
he's where it was here dude they got so
we got we were so delayed to go to into
we were flying into New York from
Albuquerque I was just me and we were so
delayed the and they they this flight
was crazy all right it was from
Minneapolis I think to new JFK and the
you decide this because the the
stewardess or I don't know if they just
calm stewards now because you know that
times are changing but the she was
so she sounded so drunk it was
unbelievable dude okay
citizens talking about it again happy
gonna have your your your chairs up in
an upright listen that's all good like
that's what she was saying upright
position so this is the [ __ ] that she
was saying here you decide if she's
drunk or not do it okay you decide a
surgeon
oxygen dude so drunk and then she would
walk down I be trying to smell this girl
I'm like I'm certain look at her she
didn't look drunk dude she's like 50
dude I couldn't believe it
I saved this [ __ ] and there's another
one hold on okay and then I and then I
thought maybe and then some weird [ __ ]
was going on and this dude oh dude I was
sitting at a bar before because the
flight was delayed so much I got [ __ ]
salmon because you know I'm healthy
babies you know how I do it
and this dude was sitting next to me and
he was so loud and he was drunk and he
was just he would do he would let he
would be like oh cuz you know Tom Brady
yadda yadda like so loud and then he
would laugh and he go oh and I was like
oh and I was I wanted to [ __ ] knock
this guy out right but I was like maybe
he's got a problem it's all good you
know maybe he's got a drinking problem
and as you know I feel for that right so
we were so late and then we we exited
the gate and we were about to take off
and then the pilot goes like this so
ladies and gentleman with customer
service and I just go I I rolled my eyes
so hard
I thought they fell on the floor okay
and then I was like what's going on and
then I look behind and there's this guy
standing up and it's that guy and he's
like well I don't know where my bag is
and the stewardess is like okay well
we'll find it and he was like I don't
know which one I don't know where it is
he couldn't remember where he put his
[ __ ] bag dude up on the top of the
thing he found one he was like I have a
computer bag back there somewhere
it's like okay well we'll find we got to
get it we got to get him off the plane
he was so drunk they got him off the
plane they kicked him off the plane cuz
he was drunk and then the pilot goes
like this they kicked him off so we went
back to the gate and then we started to
leave again and this [ __ ] eye tell me
she's not drunk now she's talking like
this what is she saying bro I was like
this I was on the plane like this and
nobody's paying attention I'm like this
girl is drunk as [ __ ] dude oh she hiccup
what and as you've been traveling to New
York your lives has been trapped for you
your luggage has been trapped for you
okay there's there's and then there's
this one dude what's it just
I said that's when she almost [ __ ]
threw up in her mouth I see it customer
ever was in love that's what she said
hold on just listen dude kick her off -
it's been a pleasure having on board
this evening Marlene how okay here's the
thing if she's not drunk then she's got
a speech impediment I feel for you but
why are you the one that's talking to
everybody on the plane dude I'm so sick
of this [ __ ] man we were all so in
trying to fly home and the guy that they
tried there oh dude the airports are
[ __ ] insane dude I swear to God if I
saw and I mean no [ __ ] if I saw a
wild boar working the desk at like one
of the airlock I would be like that's
weird but you know yeah I guess it makes
sense this is why everything so [ __ ]
up like it's uh it's insane dude I I was
we were we were waiting and and the guy
who was talking to the people first of
all everyone's in line the flights
delayed we're at the airport okay and
everyone's in line and and the guy who
is on the over the loudspeaker is like
he's so Indian and that's fine to be
Indian but this guy was killing it with
the Indian [ __ ]
he was just like lovely a little bloated
all and everyone and I caught that he
was like flights delayed and we will be
boarding soon
people are just lined up dude sit the
[ __ ] down dude
what do you we're all getting on the
plane all of us are getting on the plane
also the people who are lined up aren't
even group Hey
and guess who group guess who's in Group
A daddy and he's sitting all the way
[ __ ] down man
his knees are bent dude you keep your
[ __ ] legs straight
you better be laying the [ __ ] down
because that's crazy to be lined up when
the flights delayed and you got this guy
who's telling us the flights delayed
we're all going to the same place I
don't get it
I don't get it um so so yeah we couldn't
understand this guy because he was just
they always give it to the [ __ ] guy
who like can't talk in English which is
you know and I'm not I'm not saying like
a learn the [ __ ] language like I'm
not I love that America's Got all the
different types of people and all the
different cultures and all the different
accents it's awesome you might as well
just speak in your language though if
you're gonna do that I don't I can't
understand I sound so [ __ ] 80 years
old right now but yeah yeah we got an
oxygen mass in oxygen too also don't it
but if the person is drunk oxygen is the
number one word that your [ __ ] can
tell that's what the thing should be if
you're a cop okay
have you been drinking no say the word
oxygen oxygen cool you're coming with me
if you have one drink all of a sudden
oxygen turns the oxygen set customer
service customer service say oxygen
oxygen okay you're coming with me come
on in the drunk tank whoo
are you drunk no sir I don't you could
be so good at hiding it Oh sir I'm
completely not drunk are you drunk no
not at all how many drinks have you had
my I had one drink at dinner and that's
it oh really yes and you had no other
drink zero other drinks well sir say
oxygen oxygen
all right cool you're coming with me
[Music]
yeah
kicked off imagine getting kick he was
so not embarrassed to I guess it was cuz
you were drunk it was killer this guy
was like are you kicking me off cool he
was making a scene he was like cool I'll
just get off the plane like this guy I
would have been like yo listen sorry I
had too much to drink
give me some [ __ ] bread give me some
bread and a muzzle I'll be fine tie my
hands up I'm getting it [ __ ] JFK
mm-hmm a surgeon dude awesome you know
Wow
guess what guys we fixed the microphone
stand and it is syncing ever so slightly
ever so ever so slowly it's sinking now
that means my anger is just growing at a
very slow snail space and it's all good
but my anger is growing because the
microphone can't stay up and it's the
only thing but it's ever so say ever and
it's okay but I'm getting angry no it's
okay I'm getting angry I'm getting angry
yes is that okay man barely you know can
I sink - yes it's good thing about this
plane yes I can also lower body yes it
doesn't make me mad yes does make the
podcast better sometimes does if you
like when I complain or not
why am I gonna come by yes it's all good
of course only two things you need when
you're doing a podcast or a microphone
and oxygen and I have oxygen uh airports
are so [ __ ] and they don't even give a
[ __ ] man I mean I travel so much dude I
could go back to [ __ ] Albuquerque I
got a [ __ ] Albuquerque I think on
Wednesday or some [ __ ] dude I was in
Albuquerque first two days and I I was
there I flew in I had a whole day there
I did my my [ __ ] the meetings that I had
to do and I was done in like two or
three and the rest of the day I was like
alright cool I worked out a little bit
keep my back all [ __ ] mountainous you
know what I mean I did some [ __ ]
chin-ups just to make sure the lats kept
like a turtle shell
I did some [ __ ] chest exercise to
make sure that [ __ ] you know what I
mean I keep my Sikh Cup and I did
shoulders exercise of course because I
wanna keep the documentary [ __ ] I
want to keep the documentarian happy
because they're probably doing a
documentary on my shoulders or some [ __ ]
so I was in Albuquerque and let me tell
you something man it was for one day and
I was leaving the next day and bully is
it boring it's hot as [ __ ] I mean 11
o'clock I landed and I of the day before
and I was like hey guys is there a place
to eat or something and they were like
no they didn't even like think they're
like there's Burger King and I was like
hey look at me do I look like I wanna
[ __ ] do I look like I need fast food
right now at 11:00 look at me and they
were like yeah no I mean you do keep
your back like a turtle you know it's
like a turtle shell and I I saw a
documentary crew like trying to be
sneaky you know obviously [ __ ] trying
to shoot your shoulders and we get it
you should be wearing a bra so I don't
know so I'm just night so I went to a
[ __ ] place in downtown Albuquerque
and I walked in oh by the way I was like
is there any I was like oh I found a
place on Yelp I was like it's open and I
went to the lobby the people at the
lobby and I was like hey guys so I found
a place that's open I was like I just
you know I guess because I don't know
that area is this area safe to go here
and they were like oh yeah it's [ __ ]
fine of course it's totally safe and I
was like I could cool got me uber and
then the uber driver
no [ __ ] he was like are you Crystal
Leah and I was like yep he's like ah
cool no way I was like I yeah he's like
why go on this place I was like oz you
only place open to eat and he was like
oh yeah there was a someone shot seven
people next door a week ago hey that's
safe what's dangerous what was there a
[ __ ] zombie yeah well there haven't
been zombie attacks
now there hasn't been a zombie attack
there so yeah oh dude
seven people got shot that's the
definition of danger and I went there
and I was like really and he goes like
yeah he's like yeah he's like I know cuz
I'm a crime-scene investigator oh I'm
checked out hey went in it what a guy
driving you in your uber says just so
you know just so you know just so you
know it could be the truest [ __ ]
it could be truer than the sky is blue
or I live in a house okay when an uber
driver says whether it's true or not cuz
you know in the daytime I'm a
crime-scene investigator you're just
lying
because huh imagine [ __ ] what's his
name David Caruso in that show whatever
the [ __ ] he is where he puts his CSI
where he puts his glasses on and then
walks away like the illest [ __ ]
alive dude David Caruso Wow
you know something was definitely true
about David Caruso he never got his ass
kicked
that's you can tell that about David
Caruso so much just by the way he acts
because if you got your [ __ ] ass
handed to you you would never act that
badass that guy act so badass he acts
like nobody ever [ __ ] ever said no or
[ __ ] me up I'm on the [ __ ] that guy and
I'm not saying this because of any like
ill you know opinion I have of him or
anything but that guy technically needs
his ass beat because you can't act like
that but he acts like that and he just
you know I mean some of the [ __ ] just
look at some of this [ __ ] but imagine
this imagine you're a crime-scene
investigator and and then uber by night
CSI David Caruso one-liners there we go
first thing that comes up obviously
because they're ridiculous Horatio
Caine's the fact that his name is
Horatio Kane
you know sunglasses moments just listen
drive-by Miami style and then and then
he [ __ ] hat it puts his glasses on
every time dude it's so hilarious
question becomes Alex was the mob sent
two draws to the crime scene
was sent to destroy it
always the beginning of the show dude
and then I got all these stories get up
and run away you do got something to
hide because I never got his ass kicked
never [ __ ] does so many you know what
he does he's oh wow
for sure David Caruso thinks he's a
black belt in karate because he practice
all himself had never got instructed on
karate at all he just did it worked on
it in his room and he's like I'm
applying and he would tell something I'm
a black belt and it's cuz he thinks that
he [ __ ] did karate every day and he's
like I've worked on it I'm a black belt
- he says - like [ __ ] took off maybe
he got taken for a ride bad you know the
write what the writers wrote every
script with only a shirt on no pants on
and their dicks out on the chair and
they never cleaned the chair and they
what other people use the chair and they
didn't give a [ __ ] for instance you came
down to drink my kid son looks like that
one made it up himself he tells him to
leave it blank he tells the writers to
leave it blank leave it blank and then
they go okay he's like I'll come up with
it on the day and then he himself goes
and walks out the room
so our accident is not an accident at
all oh [ __ ] dude oh you know there's
somebody on the crew that wants to
[ __ ] lay him out and he's just every
time they shoot those he's just like god
damn [ __ ] one day I'm gonna kick
his [ __ ] ass
[Music]
we just said here we go on our cloud
quick tide is rising and we have a
sinking crime scene Wow
it's not looking too good a ratio on the
contrary there's a chance this girl is
alive and we that's not even one that's
even one the writers were like let's try
and do it so he can't do it and he still
did it
I wanna bagel at the [ __ ] in a
restaurant so and what will you be
having his wife's I'll just have a Cobb
salad and what would you like I would
like the breakfast sandwich as a new
breed of Crow
I'm gonna get to the truth not even one
dude what is this song it's the who
write what what is it dude Wow
I mean that's so funny dude I love that
[ __ ] I don't want to [ __ ] I got a
play that [ __ ] that dude
I'm Horatio Keynes I don't give a [ __ ]
the who what what's the song do you know
oh yeah it is who are you yeah I think
it's that one right but not that's not
what's called is it is it no it's got to
be one of these hold on it's not that
one I mean all right guys you know we
get it they did that song it's called
who are you okay I'm looking I'm looking
I'm looking baby I'm what's that that's
what's called won't get area yeah that's
it Wow when do they start screaming
though
after this it's like after our first
whenever
yes it's time to head back yeah we do
that one I start out coming a mile away
they're trying to get our attention
I don't know but he just got my Alex let
just now us down to one okay what does
it even mean or his ass hauling us Frank
a dead body can have that effect on you
few more words already my verdict is any
friends
guilty as charged that was a good one
that was my favorite one Wow
oh wow very big but very coarse though
we've got is that fall sir status she's
either dead or dying oh wow who's on the
move he was on the move that was bad
kids they're not gonna get away with
murder gonna get away with murder
dude my uber driver doesn't do that you
know imagine you I got in there were
other people in the car and I was like
what the [ __ ] who are these people and
he says you seemed to have ordered an
uber pool oh man I'm dying yeah what the
[ __ ] were you going well it seemed
somebody has changed your location Wow
dude oh my god how come you're asking me
so many questions because you didn't
yeah because you didn't click quiet
preferred dude you're you're just it's
fine you're Newburg driver but imagine
this guy showing up first of all
dropping someone off a block away and
then showing up to the crime scene
[ __ ] what do you call him what do you
call those microphone no Sherlock Holmes
microscope we call those I glad
magnifying glass yet [ __ ] oh my god okay
uh we got to do ads it's [ __ ] way
late it's all good ah go Yeezys Jordans
off whites if you're going to buy
sneakers for a few hundred dollars how
can you be sure they're the real thing
goat comm is the safest way to buy and
sell authentic sneakers online they're
the largest market place in the world
for authentic Easy's Jordans and over
600,000 sneaker listings they've made
the whole process frictionless and
trustworthy they do this by only
accepting
sellers with the best reputation and by
verifying all sneakers to ensure their
authenticity for buyers every detail is
inspected from the stitching and color
to the size and weight Goat certifies
that every pair of sneakers on their
site matches exact factory
specifications with over half a million
sneakers on the platform and 10 million
users I'm one of them I use goat and
they always get my shoes right and if
they don't they ship them back and then
I get different ones because they make
sure they're authentic dude there's a
lot of I mean fakes out there if you're
not using goat so find the perfect 100%
authentic sneaker at Goat calm slash
Congrats
that's goat comm / Congrats plus you'll
also be supporting our show but you've
got to go right now before the sneakers
you want are gone when you go to goat
comm / Congrats spelled go8 e.com /
Congrats look mmm guys are terrible at
taking care of their health I mean I'm
just lazy and stuff whether it's a knee
injury bad back or something worse guys
are usually some more comfortable
rubbing some dirt on it than seeing a
doctor I do it - the same is true for
erectile dysfunction studies show 70% of
guys who experience edie don't get
treated for it thankfully Roman created
an easy way to get checked out by a
doctor and get treated for IDI online
Roman is a one-stop shop where you could
chat with a licensed u.s. physician who
can treat Eady and if safe a pro and
appropriate ship medication right to
your door you handle everything
discreetly online nobody needs to know
about it all you have to do is visit get
Roman comm / Congrats complete an online
visit it's like going to the doctor only
you're not going to the doctor I've got
a chat with it you get to chat with a
doctor and if the doctor decides it
would be safe inappropriate they'll ship
genuine medication right to your door
discreet unmarked packaging go online
and get checked by the doctor arrest
erectile dysfunction is a problem that
guys don't tackle but with Roman it's
really simple so just go take care of it
for a free online visit go to get Roman
comm / Congrats that's get Roman dot-com
/ congrats for a free online visit get
Roman comm / Congrats
today's show is also brought to you by
honey the easiest way to save money when
you're shopping online honestly before I
found out about honey seeing the promo
code box at checkout stressing me out
like should I be like do I type
something in here or what is our code
and just knowing that there could be a
discount out there made me worry about
overpaying every time I shipped online
every time I shopped online thankfully
now I have honey and it's a free tool
that connects to your computer's browser
and as you're shopping it scans the
internet for coupons and codes and other
discounts then it automatically applies
it to the best one to your cart at the
checkout so you don't have to do the
work if you get this if you get honey
honey will find you every coupon code
sale or discount on over 20,000 sites
like Amazon j.crew eBay Macy's Sephora
Nordstrom and and more I just bought a
bunch of new linens with and I used
honey and their way expensive but I was
on some online shop and honey does its
thing and automatically through the
Chrome extension I saved 20% or
something like that
that's free money that they helped me
get so there's no reason not to add
honey to your browser today it's free to
use and installs in just two clicks get
honey for free I join honeycomb /
Congrats that's two words
join honeycomb / Congrats honey the
easiest way to save money while shopping
online congratulations is brought to you
by the cash app the app that likes when
you head it uh
alright well yeah so that's what's up
God those Horatio's cane things are
hilarious oh these are other ones um
somebody wrote stealing his sunglasses
would be the biggest crime in Miami what
would he do
that's funny
is it Amazon Prime day by the way today
people are going nuts over that [ __ ]
people are worried people always worried
huh
the only thing that would make that
[ __ ] horatio Caine thing Rutter is if
he was like so British then he would be
Wow then he would really need his ass
kicked I was in luck I was thinking
about the other day actually about how
long it's been since I've been in London
I was in London when I was 19 and of
course it was raining the whole time but
my brother and I got up early we're like
so jazzed that we were in dude
London really has to figure out Europe
or a nut Europe but like I guess Great
Britain needs to figure out its [ __ ]
breakfast situation man when I was in
London my brother I got up early cuz we
were like jet lag we're like let's go
explore I want to go explore like let's
get some breakfast dude and we went and
first of all every place I would look a
bit like oh that's not a breakfast place
but that's not breakfast place that's
not much we finally settled on one that
you order to counter and look like a
[ __ ] breakfast place so we looked up
and we were trying to get breakfast and
they were like what do you have for
breakfast and they just pointed and the
only thing that they were serving I
swear to God my brother and I we ate for
real this was the breakfast beans and a
tomato Hey people in London
that's not breakfast that's not even
lunch or dinner that's like the [ __ ]
that you put on stuff to eat full
breakfast
full English mm-hmm uh Great Britain and
Ireland English breakfast in the full
English breakfast often consists of
bacon fried egg sausage mushrooms baked
bean toast what the [ __ ] up with beans
bro that seems like a weird breakfast
thing you should have that for lunch or
dinner cuz it'll be farting all day
oh no I'll sit going
excuse me about that I know crank being
a London breakfast so I was sorry you
know how it is here
it's 11:30 and I just digested my beans
and sausage carry on as it walks away
hello excuse me I just ate you guessed
it beans and a tomato
excuse me where's the bathroom it
doesn't matter at this point I [ __ ] my
pants
excuse me we've really got to figure out
this breakfast situation also just so
you know bacon to us it's pretty much
just not cooked all right just cut off
the side of a pig and put it in my mouth
excuse me I hate beans and the raw side
of a pig carry on just ate a tomato
excuse me do you know which way the
bathroom nevermind I [ __ ] my pants
carry on worst worst you know when
direct Jake does that sign and it starts
with worst that's what he's talking
about somebody said hey Dre before you
start recording what's the worst [ __ ]
how what do you think you're English
breakfast and he goes first and then
they started the song that's what
happened there go Drake
what do you think of London breakfast
alright music videos you know hey Drake
what we think in London breakfast worse
so not worth it for the joke Jesus
Christ took so long you know I don't
give a [ __ ] this how he do it Nicky
Drake what do you think of the breakfast
in London worse that's it what happened
to Chamillionaire bro that guy ripped
dude Chamillionaire okay I'm like a big
bun B fan and [ __ ] like that I love
rappers from the South I love what's his
name slim thug but Chamillionaire that
guy when he came out on the [ __ ]
scene I was like that's a rap dude my
favorite rapper is southern and then he
just like quit and bought an app or some
[ __ ] he's like a tech guy now bro commit
first of all his name is Chamillionaire
that's hilarious dude that song in the
trunk was the [ __ ] illest rap song in
a long time
in the trunk Chamillionaire dude it's so
funny
he's so [ __ ] make another song bro he
doesn't give a [ __ ] I think he's sitting
pretty I texted bumpy I'm from I'm
buddies with problem being bumpy we text
each other and [ __ ] I was like what
happened a Chamillionaire and he was
like yay doesn't really rap anymore now
it's like man and that's pretty much it
do you know which wipe never mind carry
on pardon me I a tomato and some beans
on the side of a pig should make that in
back to work
ah man I'm just I don't know should we
do some MIT's connections or what oh wow
chamillionaire's real name is Hakeem sir
Ikki Wow damn how old is he 39 he's my
age bro Wow
I realized my buddy was always talking
about my buddies like 53 it's not bryan
callen but he was like and he was like
hey man he's like I look good for my age
a lot of people of 53 they look [ __ ]
terrible and I was like you look 53 like
in my head I was like no you don't you
look 53 straight up and then I always
felt that way about myself like I don't
look 39 but I [ __ ] so I was like oh
dude that's just something people do in
their brains to make it okay I'm like I
[ __ ] for sure look 39 and that's it
and that's fine and I'm gonna just
accept that dude because when I see
other 39 year olds I think oh I don't
look at that but I do I'm mama [ __ ] 39
and I look that way you look your age
whether you think it or not you know I
mean unless you're like Justin
Timberlake but even I saw a picture of
Justin Timberlake the other day and he
looked old as [ __ ] so even just a
gentleman like falls it falls victim to
it and I'm not even trying to be a piece
of [ __ ] to Justin Timberlake I think
you're really crazy talented didn't mean
this but it's like you know let's do so
do we have miss connections or no we've
got some all right let's see if the news
was announced so I could [ __ ]
announce it probably not yeah let's fine
what are the miss connections where are
they at Detroit nice where minut where
my show is gonna be whoops um where my
show is gonna be live here I mean so
ridiculous first of all the first thing
here we go that says
[ __ ] you helped carry my kayak first
of all I didn't I guess I didn't really
think about this because I guess there
are lakes all over the place hold on is
did it did they tweet it yet no did they
tweet en I'm looking at Hollywood
Reporter here you help carry my kayak
you saw me having a hard time carrying
my kayak down the rollers don't know
what that is and graciously ran up to
help me you were wearing a black one
piece with the cutest little behind a
sexist I know I seemed preoccupied and
didn't thank you properly please accept
my apologies and know that I would love
the opportunity to thank you for the
smile you're a shorter blonde very
pretty and a heart of gold I'm sure I
mean so letting yourself getting carried
away whether they give them no idea you
were sitting with your mother sister
that trying to be nice about the mother
saying she look young slim chance you'll
see this thank you again do not contact
me unsolicited services or offers I mean
dude you don't have to describe the girl
that much dude she's like how many girls
helped us a guy with a [ __ ] kayak in
Detroit you know like there's [ __ ] 17
women just looking at this just like a
[ __ ] man I don't know I wonder if anyone
gotten matched off this show because
they don't watch the they don't listen
to the what do you call it miss
connections but our show was like wait
that was me I was carrying that guy you
think Eminem wrote that one here we go
miss miss you Southfield
I miss you Lisa you're you are Detroit
fan you know who I am
I mean and then there's that there's the
guy who's not specific enough Lisa I
miss you you are Detroit Finn you know I
am that's a creepy and a hard beginning
of a horror movie and it's all good do
not contact me unsolicited services or
offers okay
so Lisa if you're listening hit up
[ __ ] this creepy ass dude in Detroit
let's go to the next one
Wow supper so poetic
we met eyes twice imagine reading that
you're like wait a minute I did meet ice
guys I mean I did meet eyes twice with
somebody today we met eyes twice this
afternoon I was leaving 7-eleven as you
came in I wish I would have spoke to you
if this description leaves you unsure it
wasn't you
oh wow this guy is for sure banking on
the fact that that person who he met
eyes with definitely registered him this
guy has a high ego he has a high opinion
of himself and that's okay because they
say men have to have a high opinion of
mrs. they have to think that girls want
to sleep with them because that's what
makes them aggressive and that's what
makes other humans come out of you know
it makes you have sex and then come
inside of a girl and the girl has a baby
and then it keeps human race going on
that's how it needs to be sometimes guys
that's why guys whenever they talk to a
girl
oh dude she I think she likes me cuz
that's a [ __ ] nature that's crazy
dude I'm really smart I'm a scientist
going next one nope that's it Oh miss oh
I thought it said [ __ ]
mature CMT looking for a masseur
certified preferred must have a studio
does he mean masseuse masseur has moved
out of state thank you dude go to a
[ __ ] website dude why do you want
Craigslist that people go people will go
on Craigslist and be like need groceries
hey if you're out there and you and you
own a [ __ ] shop right let me know
need badly celery and pancake batter and
milk and eggs trying to make pancakes do
not contact me on solicit or resort just
go to [ __ ] Ralph's dude go to [ __ ]
Vaughn's it's so weird dude no no more
no more the rock on tours
wha-what looking for the cute flight
attendant who sings opera I was working
what what the [ __ ] is who wrote this one
David Lynch what kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] is
this hey was this as a Fellini movie
dude looking for the cute flight
attendant who sings opera make sure all
of you the you observe the no-smoking
sign also what were you working on as if
you were on a [ __ ] plane what were
you doing dude I was an assassin
I was busy assassinating and you were
the [ __ ] operatic what it what maybe
they just had a conversation about how
she oh he was probably working on his
laptop or some [ __ ] maybe that's what he
means dude be more specific bro these
[ __ ] ads need to be more specific or
less specific and that's very general
but it is what it is and that's honestly
the truth said it yes that's it talked
about all the things in the world that I
wanted it's Amazon Prime day what does
that even mean that you could just go
and get a bunch of stuff for cheap is
that what Amazon Prime day is two day
parade of epic deals that's what it says
it's not a parade but it's all good
you can't call some a parade if it's not
a parade dude a parade is one thing
walking down the street holding signs
and streamers and [ __ ] and most of the
people are you know probably terrible if
you're in a parade unless it's like for
something like Pride even still but
probably pride is a good one or but like
if you're just in a parade like fair
like Thanksgiving
you're probably just like kind of
terrible you know bayonetta thing on
there we go marching band imagine being
in a marching bagging Band in 2019
dude we have iTunes we have Spotify
being play the French horn or some [ __ ]
right there's so many horns you know
[ __ ] chill have one [ __ ] type of
horn and then a guy you don't need the
guy with the baton I don't give a [ __ ]
people should just be definitely
marching to the beat without a [ __ ]
guy that's just I mean is there anything
more annoying than that and then flutes
like alright fine
even though that's everything in a
[ __ ] marching band is annoying as
[ __ ] you got horns that are just and
then you got [ __ ] so annoying we all
have Spotify all good take off those
[ __ ] feathered hats never have a
feather in your hat dude you're not a
bird keep the feathers on the birds keep
the feathers on the goddamn birds man
don't ever have a feather anywhere on
your body period what are you an Indian
no you're just some white guy with a
tall hat don't have a feather on your
body you're not a bird oh I'm itchy dude
I'm itchy man so it's [ __ ] I'm gonna
be done I'm done dude but I am itchy I
[ __ ] love you guys man
thanks for listening I'm gonna go to
Albuquerque again it's gonna be so
[ __ ] boring but I'll be there and
that's that and I'm done and you know I
don't know what the [ __ ] but
I guess that's it download the cash app
for free on the App Store or Google Play
market download the Chris D'Elia app see
the show a little bit of it live before
it goes and get tickets for my mini it
for my Minneapolis show I'm doing my
Netflix taping I think it might be
almost sold out and the reschedule on
the Chicago show is a New Year's Eve and
the day before that as well Detroit is
on sale it might be sold out at this
point and that's it thank you guys so
much you guys are great have a good one
[Music]